[Music]
that's a freelancer I have the
flexibility to work well in that school
or do you work late at night or you know
not work that week because I'm busy
Cassie Dylan is getting a master's in
public policy at Pepperdine University
and works as a freelance journalist to
help support herself through school I
live in LA it's not cheap and so
freelancing gives me an opportunity to
have income on the side and pay for
graduate school and you know not how to
take out student loans now I might be
forced to take out student loans because
now I can't do my freelancing since
January Dylan has been finding it much
more difficult to make ends meet because
of a new California law that limits the
extent to which companies can use
contract labor California assembly bill
5 was designed to constrain the growth
of the so called gig economy based on
the theory that companies like uber lyft
and post mates are taking advantage of
contract labor the bill was authored by
Assemblywoman Lorena Gonzalez a former
union leader who declined reasons
interview requests it was passed last
September with strong support from
organized labor their politicians their
union workers their people who don't get
it they're activists and so when you're
in journalism you really have to prove
yourself before you can join an outlet
it's very very competitive there's a lot
of people doing it they're cutting
people off from opportunity and what
this is going to do is it's just gonna
reach these outlets not hiring people
from California this is a really unusual
position for people in creative fields
like freelance journalism to be in by
nature most of us are liberal
progressive Democrats and we're also Pro
Union for the most part and here we are
saying this goes too far
Randy doe Tinga is a SAN diego-based
freelance journalist and the former
president of the American Society of
journalists and authors unlike Cassie
Dylan who was a conservative 13y
aleene's more to the left
this is to pro-labor and it neglects us
as workers and as people who work
independently as people who may not need
protections of employments Doh Tinga was
part of a group that lobbied
Assemblywoman Gonzalez to exempt
journalists from the law instead she
allotted them a max of 35 submissions a
year per client was it a little
arbitrary Gonzalez told The Hollywood
Reporter regarding how she came up with
that number yeah writing bills with
numbers like that are a little bit
arbitrary there are a lot of people that
write more than 35 submissions a year
per clients they might write a blog post
in 20 minutes they might write dozens of
blog posts every month or every year and
a lot of publications don't have the
resources that put someone like that on
staff so they're either gonna be limited
in what they can write or they're just
gonna be let go
Vox which held the new law is a victory
for workers everywhere announced in
December that it will be ending
contracts with more than 200 freelancers
who lived in or covered California those
200 freelance contracts will be replaced
with 20 part-time or full-time staff
positions we've heard from many
freelance journalists who are talking
about leaving the state people have been
in complete panic about this law the
American Society of journalists and
authors has filed the lawsuit on the
grounds that the bill is
unconstitutional whether or not the
group prevails venadu ball a law
professor at University of California
Hastings says that many writers are
already technically exempt in addition
to this 35 article limit that is
contained within 85 there is a broader
carve out in the law so workers who make
twice minimum wage and who are engaged
in creative work are also exempt from
wage orders but that exemption perhaps
can be made more clear the text of a B 5
doesn't mention this exemption which
comes from California's Labor Code and
how it would apply to creative
professionals like journalists in the
context of this new law is largely
unclear and up to interpretation do ball
concedes that media companies wary of
legal challenges are unlikely to take
advantage of this carve out because they
are so worried about lawsuits and
because they have such little money in
the bank at this point a lot of of the
attorneys that work for these companies
are saying well we're just not gonna
take any risks the law doesn't apply to
all contract employees dozens of
professions are fully exempted including
many healthcare jobs commercial
fishermen grant writers hair stylists
fine artists and more so I apply the
bill to any industry in the lead-up to
its passage most lip service was paid to
the plight of uber and lyft drivers what
drivers tell me is that they don't
actually have flexibility they have to
work during a particular period of time
otherwise they're not making any money
they claim that workers have flexibility
but when they're paying workers very
little wages you're looking at workers
working driving 14 16 hours a day
there's no flexibility in that if you
have such little bargaining power with
with the folks that you're consulting
with or you're freelancing for then it's
exploitative and so in this particular
context in the gig economy context it is
exploited of in November of 2019 a
coalition of drivers protested at the
home of uber co-founder Garrett camp
because we categorize as independent
contractors we don't have a lot of the
protections that comes of having
employee status hopefully now when the
New Year rolls in we're able to see some
of those protections but the average
Californian lyft driver is part time
with the average contractor spending
about three hours a week on the app and
according to a 2019 study commissioned
by lyft the company will likely have to
end its arrangements with around 250,000
drivers in the part-timers who make up
the majority would be the first to go
according to that same study 95% of
Californian drivers say that the jobs
flexibility is extremely or very
important to them and yet quarrel its
cally a spokesperson for mobile workers
Alliance which is trying to unionize the
industry says that workers would be
better off if uber and lyft were forced
to rely primarily on full-time workers
earning higher salaries for us is about
focusing on ensuring that jobs hat are
good jobs right if we have one or a
hundred jobs that are paying less than
minimum wage there is absolutely no
benefit we're at I rather have you know
50 good jobs than a hundred bad paying
jobs and those 50 good jobs are actually
a living wage according to data from up
work a site that pairs businesses with
freelancers and the Federal Reserve
about 20% of the American labor force
freelanced on a part-time basis in 2019
if a law like this went national
many of these roughly 35 million people
would need to look for other
arrangements I hope that there's some
way that the labor movement can look at
planters of all types and saying this is
a valid honorable profession that we are
workers too many of us choose this field
we are not exploited
we're not scabs we're small businesses
and we deserve to be treated that way